I'm John Krasinski and I'm Michael Kelly
and this is the wired auto complete
interview
pull it together we haven't even gotten
the intro out oh I'm sorry okay
do you want to take more time
how many movies has John Krasinski
directed technically I've directed five
movies the fifth one is a movie called
if that I just finished directing a few
weeks ago so I can't even believe I'm
vertical I'm not I'm in a chair but uh
close enough uh yeah it would be five
movies thanks for asking Michael yeah my
pleasure you should know that as a
friend of mine
what did John Krasinski do in free guy
played a small voice Ryan Reynolds asked
me to do a voice in the movie on my
phone I was a guy that looked like he
was in the witness protection program
and I believed made an inappropriate
comment uh in a sexual innuendo as they
call it you should see the movie I did
see the movie I did not know yeah how
about that you don't know anything about
look at that I thought we were I should
I should do more Googling where was John
Krasinski a waiter anywhere that would
have me I was fired from nine different
jobs while pursuing acting but not just
waiting jobs oh no it wasn't just the
restaurant business that said no I
worked at a yoga studio I was a illegal
real estate agent still being followed
by lawyers about that and what else did
I do I was a uh a casting associate
where I read with other actors in the
room how was John Krasinski and Shrek
who was John Krasinski and Shrek oh boy
um didn't know you'd be teaching him
reading I'm reading upside down yeah
that's not true right it up is that I'm
like this man I played sir Lancelot in
Shrek which is really the only thing
that makes me cool in my house as of now
because my kids otherwise thought I was
an accountant because my wife was in
Mary Poppins which was a little bit of a
cheap shot to bring that into a kid's
space my kids can't see anything that
I'm in except for Shrek so there we are
yeah John Krasinski favorite Office
episode wow that's a hard question to
answer I would have to say my favorite
Office episode was diversity day it was
technically the second episode but it
was the first episode of our own meaning
the pilot was a direct copy of the
British show the whole script was the
exact pilot of the British show so
diversity day was our first episode that
was ours and ours alone and I will never
forget that because being in that room
Not only was I the most unprofessional
actor because I laughed at every single
thing that happened and I totally
through the being in a documentary out
the window I was like no I'm gonna laugh
at everything all these people do but I
remember feeling in the room and looking
around all these people who didn't think
anyone was going to watch the show and
we still didn't think anyone would watch
the show but I said this is going to be
one of the funniest things that's ever
been recorded on television too bad no
one will see it because who knows where
this show goes and I went back to
waiting tables true story after we shot
the first four episodes I was like best
thing I've ever done no one will see it
uh and I signed up to wait tables again
the hardest I've ever laughed in my life
is the Christmas episode where Steve
pretends to be Santa and asks Brian
Baumgartner who played Kevin to sit on
his lap and as soon as Steve said what
would you like little boy and he lost
all the air in his body when Brian sat
on him I've never laughed harder in my
life and if you're a fan of the show you
know that they used to just swing pan to
gym for a reaction and I looked over to
the cameraman I said don't even try it I
will not be here and so every time he
swings to uh it was an empty room I just
wasn't there I just told him I will not
be here I'm not professional and I'll be
here on the floor laughing my ass off
and we didn't can John Krasinski ice
skate I can ice skate thank you for
asking poorly but I can do it growing up
in Boston it was very cold so there's
very few things to do when it's that
cold so ice skating was was definitely
on the docket did you ever in a in a
anything on camera
I did my first commercial ever actually
yeah weird maybe that's my question oh
okay I think it was the first commercial
I ever acted in was it Dunkin Donut spot
where you were a fan that won a fantasy
with the Boston Bruins and so I got to
skate with the Bruins and I skated out
on the ice and was supposedly supposed
to be checked by one of the Bruins
players we did about 20 or 30 takes and
it was always funny but not funny enough
because it didn't look like he really
hit me and I said on this last one
really hit me and it's the one they use
he kicked me six feet off the ice and my
skates come into the frame and I landed
and my knee wasn't right for about six
years so thanks Dunkin Donuts you'll be
hearing from my lawyer
let me see if I can read this upside
down does Michael Kelly speak Spanish
no no no no no no no I had to learn it
I had to learn it for Jack Ryan and I
did not speak a word of it and when I
was offered the job the guys who were
pitching into me I said look guys I'm I
really want to do this show super
interested but I don't speak a word in
Spanish so if you want to find somebody
who does I completely understand I
really want to do it and they're like no
no it's just a little bit cut to getting
the scripts and and freaking out when I
saw how much Spanish I had to speak and
do interrogation scenes and I was like
guys I don't speak any Spanish so I had
to learn it for the show who Michael
Kelly actor Criminal Minds I'm gonna
decipher it as was Michael Kelly on
Criminal Minds or so you were what I
think they mean Person of Interest it
was their first failed spin-off
um to the best of my recollection it was
me and Forest Whitaker and uh Janine
Garofalo but we did a spin-off and we
lasted all of One season our spin-off
was on their show and then we did a
season of our show and then they
canceled us because it wasn't good thank
you we are answer you for okay
uh that's the weirdest that is the
weirdest Google search well this gets
weirder who is Michael Kelly guitars I
just love that question this is actually
interesting there is a Michael Kelly
guitars they are and they're they make
some really rad guitars too and I've uh
don't send them one they're sending me
one no we've been in contact on
Instagram and they were like we'd love
to send you a guitar and I was like cool
because I play guitar so I was like
right on and he does Instagram and he's
cool there you go yeah there you have it
folks where does Michael Kelly live and
what time do you shower no right like I
lived in New York City for 25 years and
we have kids now and we just recently
left the city and moved about an hour
north to some beautiful horse country do
you want to drop a pen or yeah yeah just
drop it show everybody come on over and
visit
amazing
when did John Krasinski play Mr
Fantastic last year I was lucky enough
to have a small cameo role in Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness
what knife does John Krasinski use in a
quiet place wow that's a great question
and I wonder if it comes from Andy the
owner and uh artist of half face blades
and he's an ex-navy seal that I worked
with gone into his own business of
Designing knives and so when I uh was
directing quiet place I thought I'm
going to call Andy and see if he'd give
me one of his Kick-Ass knives for quiet
place and so that's the knife that's uh
hanging from my bag the whole movie and
they're so sharp they will take your
entire armor not a finger your arm off
they really are they're badass and mine
is under my bed like he gave us he gave
us the Jack Ryan guys knives as well and
those who ever asked where he lives
exactly where does Mike Gilly live you
don't want to know was John Krasinski in
every episode of The Office probably
wasn't in every episode I don't know the
answer to that question I would imagine
I wasn't in every episode it felt like I
think I was in almost every episode but
there were episodes where characters
went on road trips or things like that
that not all of us were in although I
was probably in the cold open to that to
those episodes so right that's a big
question mark so thank you for searching
it when you find out the answer let me
know John you were actually only missing
in what episode of The Office thank you
so I was in 208 episodes is that right
wow yeah I think that's right hi I'm old
I was in that I missed one as well 71 of
the 72 House of Cards 209's more but
everything is a competition everything
everything is John Krasinski so mean no
how is John Krasinski related to Stanley
Tucci Stanley Tucci is my brother-in-law
he married my wife Emily Blunt's sister
they met at our wedding got married soon
after that it was a pretty exciting
thing love was in the air that day sure
was Michael Kelly
House of Cards
yes
yes dude the wording of your questions I
know it's Michael Kelly House of Cards
you know what it is five-year-olds do
mine Doug Sanders the craziest thing I
think and he killed people so this is
he's so out there that he thought he
could control his alcoholism by giving
himself measured doses through a syringe
that's how he consumed his shots of
alcohol and funny enough one day
they I did a full shot of bourbon on the
show because they actually filled the
syringe with yeah
aerator I mean these are statements and
questions I know but yes I am yes I did
I did a Stephen King book on tape
Joyland it's a creepy ass book man it's
crazy dude crazy based on your reading
skills it must have been a really long
time really long time to get through
that I'm sorry to Stephen no it was
crazy big hero of mine sorry that you
chose him I would have done a better job
I want to hear you read that so bad
you'll get through a chapter
Michael Kelly Sopranos statement
yes I did The Sopranos it was at that
point in my career when you uh when
they're like all right we should
probably stop doing guest stars but my
manager called me was like it's a
Sopranos they want you to come to an
episode and I think it's something that
you are going to want to tell your kids
one day that you're a part of so it was
season six and I remember I went to the
audition and I was just fed up it was
just a shitty time I had a beard I had a
thermal shirt on a T-shirt and it was an
FBI agent I was like I'm not shaving man
I'm just you know one of those moods and
I was like I'm not doing it and I go in
I read for it first I sat down and she
was like
what kind of FBI agent are you I was
like undercover and she was like okay
that's funny but no she was like go
ahead just read it and so I read and she
was like that was really good and then I
got called and she said do you speak
Spanish do you speak Spanish
so I went to the Callback I shaved it
was for um David Chase was there and I
was like oh wow went and I did the
episode and then it turned into I don't
know six or seven episodes of the last
two seasons it was cool to be a part of
the Supreme that's unbelievable yeah oh
these are Jack Ryan let me see I gotta
get my specs
does
you gotta show sorry does Jack Ryan
follow the books that could be answered
two ways you know it's like do we follow
Tom Clancy's books or am I by the book
kind of CIA operative see what I mean
see what I did there I do I'll let your
brain explode for a while and then what
it is is we don't actually follow the
books that Tom Clancy wrote It's a new
take on the character however
um in my opinion we always try to put in
an homage to each of the books or each
of the movies that uh that the character
is famous for this new season season
three when we came up with the idea it
was Hunt for Red October we wanted to
pay a little homage to by involving uh
Russia going getting to go to Russia but
also instead of a nuclear submarine it's
a man that we're looking for it's Intel
that we're looking for rather than a
submarine that's that was the idea there
there you have it is Jack Ryan an action
series hell yeah it is and I love it man
it's so much fun to do I mean I think
it's one of the things that we enjoy
most uh on the show and that we get to
do a lot of our our own stunts and so to
push yourself every season as I get
older
to see if I can do it still it's a lot
of fun and I got thrown out of a
helicopter so it better be an action
series or I really need to call work
people are just mean is Mike November
bad in Jack Ryan take that two ways
oh [ __ ]
yeah no no man he's he worked for the
CIA and now he's uh he's an entrepreneur
so to speak he does some questionable
things but yeah I don't think that makes
him bad not any morally questionable
person no
um yeah he does some morally
questionable things but the guy who
plays him is anything about that thanks
buddy who plays them
what does Mike November mean it's the uh
it's the military
um NATO phonetic
that's right the NATO phonetic alphabet
so NATO phonetic
like Charlie or Bravo Whiskey Tango uh
Mike November it just so happens to be
the coolest name in any certainly cooler
and Jack Ryan the same is Jack Ryan a
real story no it is not a real story it
is based on the character that was
created by Tom Clancy in various books
and also movies I think the coolest part
about the Show versus the movies the big
difference for me at least getting to
play him is that it's long-form
storytelling if you like it you can buy
a bunch of books they're they're out
there for you so Michael how was your
first wired autocomplete interview how
did that feel I really want to figure
out why people ask my questions in
statements I was really fascinated to
learn about you I know you were because
you clearly don't know anything about me
a lot of times decent friends I actually
thought that we were gonna like our kids
are friends we talk about a lot of stuff
but I was like oh wow interesting didn't
know you were anything besides a waiter
thank you wired thanks a lot I didn't
know that you're anything but a waiter
that's what that guy just said I am
going to drop that pin I'm gonna show
everybody where you live right now give
me my phone
[Music]